I believe that I would be irresponsible at
this point if I didn't come to you and say
there is an unfortunate reality.
There is an undeniable reality that if all
else is equal, if you can do it safely, we're
probably better off if you vote in person
in November or hand deliver, deliver your
ballot and track it.
If that is, if voting in person is not a realistic
or safe possibility.
Now, I don't want to encourage anybody to
do anything dangerous.
And of course, voting in person, there can
be funny business and voting by mail.
There can be funny business.
But my sense right now is that your vote is
more likely to be counted and counted correctly
if you vote in person.
And we now have an additional reason to suspect
that it is important to consider voting in
person if you can do it safely, of course,
which is that more and more data firms are
predicting that we could have an extremely
chaotic situation where because we know that
those planning to vote in person are more
likely to vote Trump and those planning to
vote absentee are more likely to vote Joe
Biden.
There is a very good possibility based on
analysis by a number of political data strategy
firms, including hawk fish, that we may well
have a situation where Trump is slightly ahead
on election night and will almost certainly
claim victory.
But as the Biden absentee votes come in, in
the set 24, 48, 72, 96 hours after Election
Day, Joe Biden may well win.
Now, we don't know that that's going to happen.
Biden might win outright on election night
and grow the lead as mail and votes are counted.
Trump may win outright on election night by
a lot, and then the margin might shrink as
absentee ballots are counted and Trump will
still win.
That's a possibility.
But Hawk Fish is now saying and they have
an upcoming interview on Axios on HBO, which
will see, I believe, over the weekend.
The CEO of Hawk Fish, Josh Mendelson, says
there is a scenario they are projecting called
the Red Mirage.
And the Red Mirage is the idea of a red victory
on Election Day, which will merely be a mirage
which will evaporate.
Right.
Continuing this mirage metaphore as we approach
100 percent counting of ballots, including
absentee ballots, at which point it may actually
be Joe Biden who has won.
And it looks like it could take five, five
or so days.
Trump is talking about we might not know the
results for months.
Trump said we might not know the results.
For years, Trump even said we might have to
redo the election.
No, that's not true.
But it could be five days, five business days
even, which is really like a week.
So this is.
Scenario that will most fuel Trump claiming
it's rigged.
If Trump is ahead on election night and really
does fall behind after all the absentee ballots
are counted, Trump will claim that it is rigged.
And in fact, in the intervening period between
Trump claiming victory on election night,
as those ballots are being counted, you are
likely to see two things, neither of which
is particularly good.
Number one, you are likely to see a wave of
lawsuits at the precinct level, at the at
the county level, at the state level, from
the Trump campaign, trying to stop the counting
of absentee ballots.
It may not work and you won't see it everywhere,
but it is almost a certainty that if Trump
narrowly wins on election night, I should
better say is ahead on election night electorally
because of small margins in a bunch of states,
which is very plausible that Trump will do
everything he can to stop the counting of
absentee ballots using all sorts of different
arguments, which we will talk about on a different
day.
And of course, those may ultimately be decisions
made by Trump appointed judges.
That's one thing that will happen if the Red
Mirage scenario is a reality.
The second thing that will happen is Trump
will claim victory and will say they're trying
to take it from me with phony absentee ballots.
And it is very plausible that this will lead
to violence in the streets from the Trump
gun people.
Now, I don't want to spend too much time on
that because we've discussed it before.
But this gets me to.
The position that I would say I want to choose
my words carefully.
I believe that all else being equal, if you
can do it safely, it's ideal to vote in person
and even vote early in person if you can.
A lot of states have early voting.
That would be the number one way vote early
and in-person.
Fewer people usually voting early.
Shorter lines.
Then it would be vote in person on November
3rd if it's safe.
If you're not high risk, I understand not
wanting to do that because of the risk of
coronavirus.
Then it would be Maylin.
But you did you hand deliver the ballot to
a ballot box?
And then fourth would be you just mail it
in.
And we hope USPS lawsuits don't stop the counting,
whatever, no matter what vote.
But this is how I would sort of rank the efficacy
of those voting options.
A lot of what's going on, we just can't control.
We're activating around, stopping destruction
of the post office.
The damage may have already been done by Lewis
Dejoy, but ultimately we can't really control
it.
We can't control voter intimidation.
We can't control voter purges.
We can't control foreign meddling.
We can't control hacking of machines individually.
I mean, obviously, we can be activists to
shine a spotlight on these problems.
We can decide how we choose to vote.
And I am leaning towards some kind of in-person
voting, ideally early, if not on November
3rd is probably the best way to both increase
the likelihood our vote is counted correctly
and decrease the probability of this Red Mirage
scenario.
Let me know what you think.